.
* Ein Hahn kräht. *
Schon als Kind haben sie
davon geträumt, Tierärzte zu werden.
Dafür müssen die Welschen
fürs Studium nach Bern.
An der Uni
sassen sie meist über den Büchern
und hatten kaum mit Tieren zu tun.
Jetzt müssen sie rund um die Uhr
für einen Einsatz bereit sein.
Der Berufsalltag ist hart:
24 Std., sieben Tage.
Darum wird jede und jeder Vierte
den Traumberuf wieder aufgeben.
Wir haben drei junge Tierärzte
begleitet:
Gwennaëlle macht eine Spezial-
ausbildung für neuartige Haustiere.
Zur Weiterbildung arbeitet sie
in Belgien in einer Spezialklinik
für Nagetiere, Vögel und Reptilien.
William macht ein Volontariat
in der Notfallstation
des Berner Tierspitals.
Im hochmodernen Spital
hat er mit kritischen und
teils hoffnungslosen Fällen zu tun.
Eléonore hat sich
den Kühen verschrieben
und arbeitet als Landtierärztin
in Porrentruy.
Es ist ein anstrengender Beruf
und man weiss im Voraus nie,
wie lange der Tag wird.
Und das sind sie:
unsere jungen Tierärzte.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Williams Tag in der Notfallstation
des Tierspitals in Bern
beginnt mit der Übergabe.
Während des Nachtdienstes
pflegte Antonella acht Tiere,
die William jetzt übernimmt.
Er ist erst seit ein paar Monaten
diplomierter Veterinär,
trägt aber schon
eine grosse Verantwortung,
weil er für die Notfälle
zuständig ist.
* Schnurren *
Eine junge Frau betritt sehr besorgt
die Notfallstation.
Es ist Laura,
die mit ihrer Katze Eustache
direkt aus dem Wallis gekommen ist.
Mein Name ist Laura,
ich bin Automechanikerin
und bin heute mit meiner weissen
Perserkatze Eustache hergekommen.
Eustache kam am 7. Mai 2015 zur Welt
und ist knapp zwei Jahre alt.
Er ist ein richtiger Stubenhocker.
Im Bericht steht,
er habe seit über 24 Std.
nicht mehr urinieren können.
Als ich am Sonntag nach Hause kam,
war er wie gelähmt.
Eustache, komm raus,
komm Hallo sagen.
Komm.
(Laura)
Er hatte so starke Bauchschmerzen,
dass er sich
kaum noch bewegen konnte.
Komm.
Die Schmerzen kommen von der vollen
Blase, was gut nachvollziehbar ist.
Wir haben auch Schmerzen, wenn wir
so lange kein Wasser lösen können.
Du riechst ein wenig.
Erzähl, was ist los?
(Laura) Mein Tierarzt sagte mir,
ich müsse sofort nach Bern fahren,
sonst sei es dann zu spät.
Viel Zeit bleibt Eustache nicht mehr.
Bleibt seine Blase verschlossen,
erleidet er bald eine Harnvergiftung
und fällt ins Koma.
Oft ist eine Stresssituation
der Auslöser einer Blasenblockade.
Hatte er zuletzt Stress?
Ein neues Baby oder ein Umzug?
Nein.
- Nichts davon.
William erklärt den Fall
dem leitenden Notarzt Rafael.
Eustache
muss notfallmässig operiert werden.
Aber erst muss William
eine Blutprobe entnehmen.
Die Venen sind hauchdünn -
es braucht höchste Konzentration.
Einem Tier kann man nicht sagen,
es soll die Pfote hinhalten.
Auch menschliche Patienten
fürchten sich oft vor Spritzen.
In der Tiermedizin ist es
aber noch etwas komplizierter,
denn ein Tier hält nie den Arm hin,
damit man
eine Blutprobe entnehmen kann.
Tiere haben Reflexreaktionen,
man muss die Pfote gut festhalten.
Oft ziehen sie sie zurück.
Das braucht Zeit und Geduld.
Man muss auch akzeptieren,
dass es nicht auf Anhieb klappt.
Was sind denn das für Venen?
Ich habe sofort eingewilligt,
dass sie alles unternehmen dürfen,
damit er wieder gesund wird.
Ich möchte ihn nicht verlieren.
Das Problem könnte ein kleines Loch
in der Blasenwand sein,
sodass der Urin
in die Bauchregion ausfliesst.
Es ist wirklich nicht einfach,
gewisse Dinge zu erklären.
Die Besitzer
sind manchmal so angespannt,
dass sie nicht verstehen,
was man sagt,
dass man sie verunsichert
und sie das Schlimmste annehmen.
Sollten wir feststellen,
dass der Kater Harnsteine hat
und wir keinen Harnblasenkatheter
einführen können,
müssten wir eine sog.
perineale Urethrostomie durchführen.
D.h., dass man den Penis
und die Hoden entfernt
und der Kater dann
wie ein Weibchen pinkelt.
Als ich ihr die möglichen
Komplikationen erklärte,
hat sie ziemlich Angst bekommen.
Es ist hart.
Meine Katze ist für mich
wie ein kleines Kind.
Ich wollte ihm
noch einmal Mut machen.
Das arme Tier ist total verängstigt.
Er war schon immer sehr ängstlich.
Ich bin sein einziger Bezugspunkt.
Ich möchte ihn nicht alleine lassen.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Anstatt einen Mann fürs Leben
habe ich eine Katze fürs Leben.
Also noch einen schönen Tag.
- Tschüss. - Merci.
Verabschiede dich.
- Bis bald.
Ade.
William versucht, eine Sonde
in die Harnröhre einzuführen,
um die blockierten Harnsteine
zurückzuspülen - Millimeterarbeit.
Wenn man dabei
die Harnröhrenwand verletzt,
kann das Tier
keinen Urin mehr absetzen.
Aber daran dürfen wir
bei einer OP nicht denken.
William ist angespannt,
aber sein Chef die Ruhe in Person.
In einem solchen Stressmoment
ist es wichtig,
dass ich ruhig
und zuversichtlich bin.
Dann ist auch er weniger angespannt.
Solange ich nicht nervös bin,
ist keiner im Raum nervös.
Wir sind in der Blase.
William hat die Harnröhre freigemacht
und den Urin
durch den Katheter abfliessen lassen.
Eustache wird es sofort besser gehen,
wenn er aufwacht.
Salut, salut. Hoi, du.
Wie geht es dir?
Streckst du mir die Zunge raus?
Du bist noch etwas trocken.
So, jetzt geht es dir wieder besser.
Ich rufe an wegen Eustache.
Wir konnten
einen Harnkatheter setzen.
Wir lassen ihn bis morgen drin.
Ist das gut so?
Okay, dann behalten wir
Eustache noch bei uns.
Ja, es lief gut.
Er ist sehr gut
aus der Narkose erwacht.
* Wehmütige Musik *
* Sanfte Musik *
Im Jura ist es eiskalt.
Bei diesem Wetter geht niemand
freiwillig nach draussen.
Aber Landtierärzte sind auch bei
schlimmstem Winterwetter unterwegs.
Grüezi.
- Guten Tag, hallo.
Wie geht's?
- Gut. Merci.
Bernard rief wegen einer
verletzten Kuh in der Tierpraxis an.
Der Bauer hängt an diesem Tier,
weil es auf dem Hof zur Welt kam.
Sorgen bereitet ihm
die Verletzung an einer Zitze.
Ich weiss es nicht, aber sie hatte
wohl Streit mit einer anderen Kuh.
Sie bespringen sich,
wenn sie stierig sind.
Vielleicht fiel sie gegen eine Wand
oder einen scharfen Gegenstand.
Die Wunde ist schon ziemlich alt.
- Ich sah sie erst gestern Abend.
Da kann mal leider nicht mehr nähen,
die Wunde ist zu alt.
Ich mache mir Sorgen.
Sie ist eine wunderschöne Kuh.
Es wäre schade, wenn diese Zitze
nie mehr funktionieren würde.
Ein solcher Schnitt kann für Linda
schlimme Folgen haben.
Mit nur drei Zitzen
ist eine Kuh nicht mehr rentabel,
weil sie zu wenig Milch gibt -
es droht der Gang ins Schlachthaus.
Aber Bernard hängt an seiner Kuh
und setzt grosse Erwartungen
in Eléonore.
Vielleicht bewirkt sie ein Wunder.
Man weiss ja nie.
Sie setzen mich recht unter Druck.
- Ja, habe ich auch gerade gemerkt.
Man muss unbedingt eine Sonde
in den Milchkanal einführen,
damit dieser nicht beschädigt wird,
sonst kann man
diese Zitze nie mehr melken.
Du bist recht geduldig, nicht?
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Ja, schon gut.
Lass mich nochmals schnell ran.
Du bist eine Liebe.
Ist es verstopft?
- Ja, es ist zu.
Ich habe einige Male versucht,
die Sonde in die Zitze einzuführen,
aber sie bleibt
an einem gewissen Punkt stecken.
Wenn ich es forciere,
wird es nur noch schlimmer.
Weiter rauf komme ich nicht.
Und wenn ich drücke,
würde ich sie verletzen.
Es tut mir leid.
Ich glaube, es ist zu spät.
Ich komme nicht rein.
Bernard ist enttäuscht: Er möchte
seine Linda nicht verlieren.
Es tut mir v.a. gefühlsmässig weh.
Ich mag diese Kuh einfach.
Ich muss es leider so lassen,
wie es ist.
Man kann sie nicht amputieren.
Das Euter ist zu voll.
Viel kann man nicht machen.
Die Natur war schneller als wir.
Im Kanalinnern
findet eine Heilung statt.
Und das Narbengewebe
verstopft den Milchkanal.
Ich darf keine Kraft anwenden,
das wäre nicht richtig.
Wir lassen es so
und hoffen das Beste.
Klar ist man enttäuscht.
Aber ich mache ihr keinen Vorwurf.
Ich weiss, dass sie präzise arbeitet
und alles Mögliche unternimmt.
Das ist ihr Job.
Sie macht ihre Arbeit gut
und ist voll motiviert.
Sie ist nicht halbherzig dabei.
Sie liebt ihre Arbeit,
das spürt man.
Eléonore muss sofort weiter.
Praxisassistentin Camille sagt ihr,
ein Schaf sei schon seit Stunden
erfolglos am Ablammen.
Sie fährt schnell los,
der Weg bis zum Hof
dauert mind. 20 Min.
Ich hatte kaum Zeit, alles
einzupacken, und bin los nach Bure.
Anscheinend ist es ein Schaf,
das seine Lämmer schon lange
hätte geworfen haben müssen.
Es habe einen rötlichen Ausfluss,
der ziemlich streng riecht.
Das klingt
nach einem dringenden Notfall.
* Blöken, Bimmeln *
Hier vorne.
- Erzähl mal von Anfang an.
Also ... Gestern ist
der Schleimpfropfen ausgetreten.
Aber seither kommt nur noch Schleim.
Die Lämmer
sind wieder weiter hinten.
Iris ist noch jung
und zum ersten Mal trächtig.
* Dramatische Musik *
Es roch streng,
das Schaf keuchte und sabberte.
So was habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Ich dachte, das sei nicht normal.
Ich habe zigmal nachgeschaut,
aber sie kamen nicht zur Welt.
Dann rief ich die Tierärztin an,
weil ich zu wenig Erfahrung habe.
Thomas ist 18 und hat seine Lehre
als Landwirt abgeschlossen.
Die Leidenschaft für Schafe
erbte er von seinem Vater.
Mein Vater
ist vor fünf Jahren gestorben.
Ich wollte die Rind- und Schaf-
haltung unbedingt weiterführen.
Als die Familie aufhören wollte,
sagte ich:
"Nein, wir machen weiter -
für unseren Vater."
Können wir sie
auf einen Heuballen legen? - Okay.
* Blöken *
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ich glaube, sie sind alle zu klein.
Sind es mehr als eines?
- Dieser Kopf ist viel zu klein.
Nachdem ich das erste Lamm
rausgezogen hatte,
sah ich ihm an,
dass er wusste, was los war.
Auch wenn es ihm Eléonore
kaum zu sagen traut,
hat Thomas verstanden:
Die Jungen sind schon tot.
Man sagt zwar, die Natur sei gut.
Aber bei diesem Anblick
denkt man völlig anders.
Das bedrückt mich sehr.
Er hat die Schafe
von seinem Vater übernommen.
Mir tut das richtig weh.
Ich lasse es nahe an mich ran,
obwohl ich das nicht sollte.
* Melancholische Musik *
Wir wissen beide,
dass die Jungen tot zur Welt kommen.
Das ist sehr bedrückend.
Damit Iris nicht auch noch stirbt,
muss man die Lämmer
aus ihr entfernen,
und zwar so schnell wie möglich.
Iris ist am Ende ihrer Kräfte.
* Blöken, Bimmeln *
* Melancholische Musik *
* Heitere, dynamische Musik *
Szenenwechsel nach Belgien,
wo wir Gwennaëlle wieder treffen.
Sie will sich im Bereich
neuartige Haustiere weiterbilden
und hat ein einjähriges Praktikum
in einer Klinik
in der Nähe von Brüssel begonnen.
In dieser Klinik werden Nagetiere,
Vögel und Reptilien behandelt.
Verglichen mit der kleinen Praxis
in Rolle ist es ein Grossbetrieb.
Am Anfang hatte Gwennaëlle
etwas Mühe damit.
Diese Woche hat sie alle Notfälle
aufgenommen, Tag und Nacht.
Mein Name ist Menoud,
ich bin Notfalltierärztin.
Unsere Ärzte sind v.a. auf
neuartige Haustiere spezialisiert.
Falls nötig, werde ich den Fall
noch mit einem von ihnen besprechen.
Vor knapp einer Woche
kauften Coralie und Nicolas
ein Meerschweinchen namens Olive.
Wir tauften es so
wegen seines südlichen Temperaments.
Stimmt, oder?
- Ja.
Wir kauften es spontan,
als wir Hundefutter kauften.
Wir liefen an den Käfigen
der Kleintiere vorbei,
und ein Meerschweinchen
schaute uns so an.
Dann dachten wir:
"Wieso auch nicht?"
Aber schon nach ein paar Tagen
kam der erste Schreckmoment.
Als ich aufstand,
hörte ich es piepsen.
Als ich nachschaute,
sah ich, dass es blutete.
Es schrie und blutete ...
Er nahm es dann raus.
Als ich es rausnahm
und am Rücken berührte,
hat es richtig geschrien,
so wie es Meerschweinchen halt tun.
Dann entdeckte ich
eine grosse Wunde.
Schauen wir es uns mal an.
Oh, Kleine.
Hat es sich im Käfig wehgetan?
Dort ist nichts Scharfes.
- Nein, ich glaube nicht.
Tut es so weh?
* Piepsen *
- Oh. - Oh.
Warte, warte!
Sonst lässt es sich streicheln.
- Es ist nicht happy.
Ja.
Und dabei
fasse ich es fast nicht an.
Ich rasiere es ein wenig,
um die Wunde besser zu sehen.
Okay.
- Danach komme ich wieder zu euch.
Gwennaëlle hat eine Ahnung,
was passiert ist.
Sie möchte Olive trotzdem
erst noch David zeigen.
Er ist auf neuartige Haustiere
spezialisiert.
Vielleicht hat es sich ...
- ... gekratzt.
Ja.
Aber hat es sich selbst gekratzt
oder wurde es in der Zoohandlung
von anderen angegriffen?
Kann sein.
Gesehen haben sie es erst jetzt.
Aber sie haben es auch erst
seit einer Woche.
Es kommt aus einer Zoohandlung.
Andere Tiere könnten ihm
die Wunde zugefügt haben.
Dort leben meist
mehrere Tiere auf engem Raum.
Es kann vorkommen,
dass sie kämpfen oder sich kratzen.
Es könnten auch
externe Parasiten sein.
Das muss man abklären.
Hast du das Gefühl, dass ...
Wir könnten ihm Antibiotika geben
oder etwas Entzündungshemmendes.
Ja, oder etwas
gegen Parasitenbefall.
Meinst du?
Es ist erst zwei Monate alt.
Zwei Monate?
Dann musst du die Dosis berechnen.
Vielleicht
kämpften sie wirklich so heftig,
dass es sich verletzt
oder gequetscht hat.
Was auch immer der Grund
für die Wunde ist,
erst muss sie gereinigt werden,
um Infektionen zu verhindern.
* Elektronisches Surren *
Man kann die Haare
rundherum entfernen,
damit die Wunde sauber bleibt
und nicht zu nässen beginnt
und Eiterflüssigkeit
das Fell verklebt.
Die Wunde muss frei sein.
Da ist ja noch ein Wunde.
Wir entdeckten dann
noch mehr Wunden.
Eine hinter dem Ohr,
eine unter der rechten Achselhöhle
und eine ziemlich grosse
unter der rechten Pfote.
Ja, das gefällt dir nicht,
ich weiss.
* Sanfte,
leicht melancholische Musik *
Da haben wir noch eine kleine Wunde.
Eine hinter dem Ohr,
die ist nicht sehr schön.
Und hier sind
ein paar kleinere Kratzwunden.
Und dann noch hier
und unter der rechten Pfote.
Mit solchen Komplikationen haben
Coralie und Nicolas nicht gerechnet.
Das habe ich nicht erwartet.
Drei Wunden -
das ist krass, ein kleiner Schock.
Hinter den Ohren
haben wir nicht nachgeschaut.
Ganz frisch
sehen sie nicht mehr aus.
Es könnte mit anderen Tieren
im Käfig gestritten haben,
bevor ihr es gekauft habt.
Moment, ich setze es hier ab.
Es ist alles nicht so schlimm.
Ich bin sehr sensibel.
Das habe ich nicht erwartet.
Ich dachte, es sei ein Kratzer.
Ohne Kruste und mit den Haaren
sieht man es nicht so gut.
Eine so grosse Wunde auf einem so
kleinen Tier, das ist beeindruckend.
Es sollte nichts Derartiges haben.
Gwennaëlle weiss inzwischen,
dass sich ein Tierarzt
auch um die Besitzer kümmern muss.
Dort drüben sind Taschentücher.
Sie versucht,
die beiden ein wenig zu beruhigen.
Immerhin ist nichts entzündet,
die Wunden sind sauber.
Man muss es aber
mit einer entzündungshemmenden Creme
und Antibiotika behandeln.
Nehmt ein bisschen
von dieser Creme ...
Am besten geht es zu zweit.
Einer kann das Tier halten,
der andere die Creme auftragen.
Schön ruhig.
Ich streiche sie
überall ganz sanft ...
Sanft, sanft, sanft.
* Piepsen *
... auf die Wunde, seht ihr?
Hier ein bisschen ... Ja, genau.
Und dann so ...
Und dann einfach weiter.
Überall drauf.
Bei dieser Behandlung sollte Olive
in ein paar Tagen
wieder auf den Beinen sein.
Also, adieu. - Danke vielmals.
- Kein Ding.
Merci.
- Danke auch.
* Leichte Musik *
In der Kleintierklinik in Bern
herrscht Hochbetrieb.
Seit dem Morgen hatte William
einen Notfall nach dem anderen.
Jetzt wir eine Französische Bulldogge
hereingetragen,
die nicht mehr gehen kann.
Der Hund heisst Jasmin.
Wir nennen ihn aber Flughund,
weil er ständig herumtollt.
Er ist sehr lebhaft und
gleichzeitig auch total anhänglich.
Bulldoggen haben einfach alles.
Grüezi miteinander.
Frau Sarrasin, guten Tag.
Ich bin der Tierarzt, der heute
für die Notfälle zuständig ist.
Am Sonntagabend
konnte er plötzlich nicht mehr gehen
und begann zu keuchen.
Er hat nicht mehr geschlafen.
Da begann ich, mir Sorgen zu machen.
Jasmin ist nicht die erste Bulldogge,
die mit Lähmungen eingeliefert wird.
Bei der Zucht von Bulldoggen
gibt es gewisse äussere Merkmale,
die sozusagen gefördert werden.
Deshalb ist auch
die Nase dieser Hunde so platt.
Zudem haben sie
eine kurze Wirbelsäule
mit extrem kleinen Wirbeln,
die in diesem Fall
anders angeordnet sind als normal.
Deshalb haben sie
oft Rückenprobleme.
Das ist bei Bulldoggen
leider keine Seltenheit.
Sie können auf dem Parkett aus-
rutschen und gelähmt liegen bleiben.
Wir haben immer wieder solche Fälle.
Die Besitzer
sind natürlich schockiert,
wenn ihr Hund ausrutscht
und nicht mehr aufstehen kann.
Kommst du nicht mehr hoch,
obwohl du aufstehen möchtest?
Ja, okay.
Für den Besitzer ist es heftig,
wenn er sieht,
dass der Hund plötzlich
nicht mehr gehen kann.
So ist gut.
Wir werden ihn untersuchen.
Meine Kollegin holt das Dossier
und kommt dann zu Ihnen zurück.
Okay, merci.
Ich habe ein furchtbare Nacht
hinter mir.
Ich war völlig machtlos
und bin eigentlich froh,
dass ich ihn jemandem
übergeben kann, der ihm helfen kann.
Der Fall ist ernst.
William untersucht Jasmin zusammen
mit dem leitenden Notarzt Rafael.
Ja.
* Ernste
auf- und absteigende Klänge *
Komm.
Komm, komm.
Er hat auf einer Seite
motorische Probleme und Schmerzen.
Er steht unter Stress, weil er
in einer fremden Umgebung ist.
Er ist desorientiert, weil er nicht
weiss, wieso er nicht gehen kann.
Schon gut, Jasmin.
Schon gut, schon gut. Sch!
Wir müssen sofort was unternehmen,
damit er nicht noch mehr Stress hat.
Wir haben keine Zeit für Unter-
suchungen und ausführliche Tests.
William testet nur die Reflexe.
* Angespannte Musik *
Hinten reagiert er nicht.
Die Reflexe der Hinterläufe
sind stark reduziert.
Wahrscheinlich ein Problem der Len-
denwirbelsäule und des Kreuzbeins,
ziemlich sicher
ein Bandscheibenvorfall.
Es könnte aber auch ein Tumor,
eine Entzündung oder ein Bruch sein.
Wenn wir jetzt nichts unternehmen,
wird der Hund
seine Hinterbeine längerfristig
nicht mehr bewegen können.
Was soll ich nur machen,
wenn er gelähmt ist?
Wir soll ich mir
meinen gesunden und lebhaften Hund
in diesem Zustand vorstellen -
auch rein praktisch?
Kann man ihn dann
noch alleine lassen?
Hätte er dann noch etwas vom Leben
oder würde er nur noch leiden?
Nur ein MRI kann zeigen,
ob er einen Bandscheibenvorfall hat.
Und tatsächlich:
Die Diagnose ist korrekt.
Eine verschobene Bandscheibe
drückt auf das Rückenmark,
was zur Lähmung von Jasmin führt.
Wir müssen den Hund
dringend operieren,
damit der Druck aufs Rückenmark
aufgehoben wird.
Deshalb wurde er sofort
in den OP gebracht.
Jasmin wird notfallmässig operiert.
Nur so kann er die Beweglichkeit
seiner Hinterläufe zurückerlangen.
Der Neurochirurg
wird die kleine Bandscheibe,
die aufs Rückenmark drückt,
entfernen.
Eine solche Operation
darf man nicht unterschätzen.
Man ist sehr nahe beim Rückenmark.
Man muss aufpassen,
dass man es nicht verletzt.
Man sieht jetzt
schon das Rückenmark.
Die grösste Konzentration
braucht es dort,
wo der Knochen sehr fein wird.
Dort ist die Hülle ums Rückenmark
relativ elastisch.
Man muss aufpassen,
dass man die Hülle nicht perforiert
und so das Rückenmark beschädigt.
D.h.,
er könnte dann nicht mehr gehen.
Oder er wäre für immer gelähmt.
* Dramatische Musik, Piepen *
Das sieht nach nichts aus,
hat aber im Wirbelkanal
enorme Folgen.
Das ist die Bandscheibe,
die aufs Rückenmark drückte.
Jetzt muss die Natur
ihren Teil dazu beitragen,
damit sich das Rückenmark erholt.
Die Operation ist gut verlaufen.
Es gab keine Komplikationen.
Die Chancen stehen recht gut,
dass sich der Patient erholt.
Ob Jasmin
wieder gehen kann wie früher,
wird sich in ein paar Tagen weisen.
* Sanfte Musik *
In Bure im Jura herrscht
immer noch grosse Anspannung.
Thomas hofft, dass Eléonore
sein Mutterschaf Iris retten kann.
Der Geruch ist unerträglich,
aber die junge Tierärztin muss
die drei toten Lämmer herausholen.
* Schmerzerfülltes Blöken *
Es ist ein besonderer Geruch,
sehr unangenehm.
Ist man ihn sich nicht gewohnt,
kann einem schnell übel werden.
Thomas hat so etwas
wohl noch nicht so häufig gerochen.
Er wurde plötzlich ganz bleich.
Ich bin so konzentriert,
dass ich es zwar rieche,
aber mich mit der Zeit
daran gewöhne.
Geht's, Thomas?
Sie ist leider dermassen erschöpft.
- Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Sie hilft mir nicht mehr.
Komm, du gutes Tier,
press noch einmal!
Die Jungen sind draussen.
Jetzt geht es darum,
das Mutterschaf zu retten.
Es wäre schön,
wenn die Mutter überlebt.
Er sorgt sich um sie.
Er hängt sehr an seinen Tieren.
Er gibt die Hoffnung nicht auf.
Es liegt ihm viel daran,
dass es gut ausgeht.
Ich bin auch so:
Ich glaube daran - bis zum Schluss.
Es sieht aus,
als würde sie es schaffen.
Thomas atmet auf.
Aber dann: die harte Wahrheit.
Nein.
Die Gebärmutter ist gerissen.
Dass die Gebärmutter reisst,
passiert bei Schafen und Ziegen oft,
weil ihre Gebärmutter sehr fein ist
und leicht einreissen kann.
Das Schaf hat keine Chance mehr.
Das weiss er auch.
* Melancholische Musik *
Ich kann den Darm spüren.
Leider ist es wirklich vorbei.
Da kann man leider
nichts mehr machen, gar nichts.
Ja, nein, das ist ...
Soll ich sie gleich einschläfern?
Ja.
Es tut im Herzen weh.
Es tut wahnsinnig weh.
Die Enttäuschung.
Wir haben uns so fest eingesetzt,
und jetzt das.
Aber ja ... So ist der Beruf.
Kannst du den Kopf hochhalten?
- Ja, so?
Oje.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Ich darf den Mut nicht verlieren.
Es läuft nicht immer
alles nach Plan.
Es gibt schöne Tage, wenn z.B.
ein gesundes Kalb geboren wird.
Und dann gibt es Tage wie heute.
Das gehört zum Beruf.
Zum Beruf, den er gelernt hat.
Auch Eléonore wird dieser Tag
in Erinnerung bleiben.
Ja, dieser Tag
bleibt in meinem Gedächtnis haften.
Zum ersten Mal
habe ich das so erlebt.
Die Enttäuschung am Schluss ...
... wird mir in Erinnerung bleiben.
Und ich möchte mich auch ewig
an diesen Tag erinnern.
* Melancholische Musik, Blöken *
* Die Musik klingt aus. *
Vor der Tierklinik
im belgischen Manage
wird Gwennaëlle
von einer Passantin angesprochen,
die auf dem Trottoir
ein ausgesetztes Kätzchen fand.
Es kroch unters Auto.
Ich traute mich nicht in den Laden -
aus Angst, es werde überfahren.
Wie kann man nur so was tun?
Ich habe selber zwei Katzen.
Plötzlich sei eine Kartonschachtel
vor der Tür gestanden.
Ich ging nachschauen
und sah ein Kätzchen und eine Frau.
Es sass unter dem Auto.
- Ah, okay.
Ich verstehe nicht ganz,
wo und wie sie es fand.
Die Kiste stand dort.
- Ah, dort drüben.
Ich bin schon seit 1 Std. hier.
Es sass darunter wegen der Reifen
und hätte überfahren werden können.
Die Kartonschachtel
lag wohl umgekippt auf der Strasse.
Beim Vorbeigehen hörte ich:
"Miau, miau!"
Ich dachte:
"Das ist doch nicht normal."
Ich weiss nicht,
wann die Katze gebracht wurde.
In der Kiste waren nur das Jungtier
und ein paar Brotresten.
Hallo, Entschuldigung?
Steht die Kartonschachtel
schon lange vor der Tür?
Haben Sie den Karton nicht gesehen?
Dieses Wochenende riefen vier Leute
wegen ausgesetzter Katzen an.
V.a. in der Ferienzeit
passiert das oft.
Wollen Sie kein Kätzchen?
- Nein, ich habe schon zwei.
Das ist doch nicht normal.
Je teurer die Sterilisation ist,
desto häufiger kommt so was vor.
Wir kümmern uns darum.
Schon traurig, das arme Kätzchen!
Adieu. - Adieu.
- Ein gutes Wochenende.
Normalerweise nimmt die Klinik
keine Tiere ohne Besitzer auf.
Aber unsere Tierretterin kann
diesem Kätzchen nicht widerstehen.
Das Kätzchen hat eine Infektion.
* Miauen *
Die Augen sind völlig verklebt,
und auch die Nase läuft.
Das deutet
auf einen Katzenschnupfen hin.
Es ist eine Infektion, die offenbar
viele Katzen in der Region haben.
Man kann sie gut behandeln.
Sie ist aber chronisch
und kommt immer wieder.
Stress kann zu Rückfällen führen.
Ein paar Tropfen Antibiotika,
und es ist in wenigen Tage vorbei.
Hast du Hunger?
Magst du fressen?
Ah, das tut gut.
Sie ist fürs Erste versorgt.
Mal schauen, wie es läuft.
Oh, ich muss weiter.
Es gibt neue Notfälle.
Ich lasse sie mal hier.
Gegen Abend schauen wir weiter.
Das Kätzchen erholt sich schnell
und wird dank Gwennaëlle
bald einen Besitzer haben.
Im Tierspital in Bern vollbringt man
jeden Tag ein kleines Wunder.
Heute freuen sich William
und sein Chef Rafael,
dass
die Französische Bulldogge Jasmin
nach der gestrigen
Bandscheibenoperation
schon fast wieder
auf eigenen Beinen steht.
* Perlende Klänge *
Sein Gang ist noch nicht optimal,
aber immerhin kann Jasmin
seine Hinterbeine wieder bewegen.
Und schon das gleicht einem Wunder.
Seine ersten Schritte
macht er mit der Neurologin Ariana.
Weil er ein besonders
interessanter Fall ist,
wird er von ein paar Studenten
begleitet.
Jasmin? Ja, super!
Das ist wunderbar.
Gut, zielt sie auf den Tierarzt.
* Lachen *
Die Harnblase funktioniert.
Wir könnten es uns
nicht besser vorstellen.
Gestern konnte er nicht
selbstständig gehen.
Er hatte auch Probleme,
Harn abzusetzen.
Und jetzt funktionieren Motorik
und Harnblase wieder.
Das ist extrem wichtig.
Er braucht jetzt noch
intensive Physiotherapie,
damit er nicht nur gehen,
sondern richtig gehen kann.
Ganz toll.
* Drollige Musik *
Jasmin wird in ein intensives
Reha-Programm eingeführt,
das gar nicht so unangenehm ist.
* Drollige Musik *
Gehen wir schwimmen?
Ja? Ja?
* Blubbern *
Alles gut? Ist alles gut?
Ja.
Noch ein bisschen?
Ja, komm.
Hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp!
Ja, super.
Ein bisschen schneller?
Anfangs hattest du etwas Angst.
Aber hier passiert nichts Schlimmes.
Jasmin, komm mal her!
Jawohl, jawohl,
jawohl, jawohl, jawohl.
Das hast du toll gemacht.
Ganz toll.
Super machst du das.
Du machst das ganz toll.
5 Min., 7 Min.
Ja, super.
In der Tierklinik in Belgien
ist es inzwischen 23 Uhr.
Nach den letzten Notfällen
kann sich Gwennaëlle auf ihr Zimmer
auf dem Spitalgelände zurückziehen.
* Heitere Musik *
Gute Nacht, Jacqueline.
Gute Nacht, Faustine.
Die anderen Praktikantinnen
haben schon längst Feierabend,
aber Gwennaëlle muss die ganze Nacht
das Notdiensttelefon hüten.
* Handy *
Notfallstation Tierklinik.
Sie muss ganz alleine entscheiden,
wie dringend es ist.
Wie ist sein Zustand?
Ist er sehr schwach?
Ja.
Wenn es besser wird
und er sich nicht übergeben muss,
ist es nicht so dringend.
Wenn nicht, müsste man ihn
möglichst schnell untersuchen.
Ist gut. Merci. Ade.
So ist die Nachtwache.
In den ersten Nächten war viel los.
Gestern war es ziemlich ruhig.
Mal schauen,
wie es diese Nacht aussieht.
Sieben Nächte Pikett am Stück.
Am schlimmsten für Gwennaëlle
ist die Müdigkeit.
Es ist jeden Abend anders.
Entscheidend ist die Anzahl Notfälle
und wie der Tag war.
Wenn tagsüber ständig was los war,
ist man abends müde
und möchte nur noch schlafen.
* Signalton der Mikrowelle *
* Gemächliche Musik *
* Handy *
Notfallstation Tierklinik, hallo.
* Ruhige Klänge *
In Bern treffen wir wieder auf Laura,
die junge Automechanikerin
aus dem Wallis,
die vor einer Woche ihre Katze
Eustache ins Tierspital brachte.
Der Kater ist ihr Ein und Alles.
Er hatte eine verstopfte Blase und
sein Zustand war ziemlich kritisch.
Jetzt ist sie gespannt,
was auf sie zukommt.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Die gute Nachricht für Laura
kommt von einer Veterinärstudentin.
* Ruhige, sphärische Klänge *
Ich hörte ihn bereits von Weitem.
Was ist das für ein Lampenschirm
um deinen Hals?
Schöne Augen hast du auch wieder.
Gebadet wurde er auch?
- Ja.
Schön.
Gehen wir kurz ins Sprechzimmer?
- Ja.
Am meisten Freude bereitet uns,
wenn ein Tier mit einem
glücklichen Besitzer heimgehen kann.
Das ist gut für unser Gemüt und
eine grosse berufliche Befriedigung.
Er hat wieder seine grossen Augen
und sieht gesund aus.
Du bist ja ganz eingeschüchtert.
Ich hole dich da raus.
Du mit dem blöden Lampenschirm ...
Er ist 3,075 kg schwer.
Ich kann gar nicht beschreiben,
wie glücklich ich bin,
dass er wieder gesund ist
und ich ihn heimnehmen kann.
Du hast nicht viel gefressen,
nicht wahr, Schätzchen?
Er hat schon ein wenig abgenommen,
aber das kommt schon wieder.
Jetzt ist besser.
Er war sicher teils auch traurig,
weil er nicht zu Hause war.
Die Halskrause
können Sie zu Hause abnehmen.
Aber Sie müssen aufpassen, weil -
ich weiss nicht,
ob Sie es gesehen haben -
es beim Penis
noch etwas entzündet ist.
Oh ja.
Er probiert immer ...
- Da ist ja alles rasiert.
... sich dort zu lecken,
was nicht optimal ist.
Deshalb trägt er die Halskrause.
Ich verbringe das ganze Wochenende
daheim mit meiner Katze.
Alle Besitzerinnen und Besitzer
hängen an ihren Tieren.
Wenn es jemandem egal ist,
was mit seinem Tier passiert,
dann hat er kein Herz
und sollte kein Tier halten.
Und schon verlässt die nächste strah-
lende Hundebesitzerin das Spital.
Carine hat ihren Hund Jasmin
fast nicht mehr erkannt.
Jasmin.
"Ist das wirklich Jasmin?"
Ich dachte erst,
es sei ein fremder Hund.
Wahnsinn, wie er nach drei Tagen
wieder gehen kann.
Jasmin kam mit gelähmten Hinterbeinen
ins Spital.
Schon vier Tage
nach der Bandscheibenoperation
trottet er zum Auto,
als sei nichts gewesen.
Findest du das Auto oder nicht?
Ich kann mich nur bedanken
und ihnen gratulieren.
Für mich ist es
eine unglaublich tolle Leistung.
Und jetzt geht es
für Jasmin nach Hause -
als wäre nichts passiert.
Und so geht es weiter
in der nächsten Folge:
Eléonore
muss einen Hengst kastrieren,
der etwas anders ist als erwartet.
Es ist das Alpaka Gaby.
Sie versucht es mit
der gleichen Technik wie bei Hunden,
aber - hoppla! - bei Gaby
sieht alles etwas anders aus.
Ist ja winzig.
In Bern kümmert sich William
um einen Berner Sennenhund,
der in einem kritischen Zustand
eingeliefert wird.
Er braucht mehrere Blutinfusionen.
Weil die Reserven des Spitals
nicht reichen,
muss der Besitzer
für eine Blutspende sorgen.
Nehmen wir diese zwei Beutel.
* Fröhliche Musik *
Hallo. Ich bin hier wegen Wizzy.
Gwennaëlle ist in Belgien in einem
Tierspital für neuartige Haustiere.
Einer ihrer Patienten
ist das Huhn Wizzy,
das nicht mehr hören kann.
* Fröhliche Musik *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Philipp Schlatter - 2020